hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now if you know about this game you know
that it is my comfort game I love this
game so much when I load up the game and
I hear the music I just get this sense
of relaxation and calm but I haven't
played the game in a while and there's
been two additional updates since the
outbreak update that caused germs to run
rampant in my facility this is the
automation upgrade and the tubular
upgrade now I don't know exactly what
these do and I need to clean my glasses
they're gross
try all the raging I just had over
getting over it why am I playing this
game well because I just played getting
over it and I need to relax I need to
get my family in space and I need to
take them through a generation of
survival and I don't care if they're
clones babies whatever they are they're
gonna survive in this place they're
gonna eat a lot of bugs and everything
is gonna be wonderful because I'm a
caretaker I take care of things I take
care of people they are not things
they're people and everything is going
to be wonderful because I know how to
play this game unless they change
something fundamental about the game
with the other updates which they may
have germs are still bad as far as I
know okay let's do this now immunity
importunes
a mole here ooh that's almost ruined all
rowing you're so cute and you're so good
at everything except you know what I'm
gonna keep you I'm gonna I'm gonna not
go for just the immunity once I like I
want to go for ones that ring true to -
ooh I like Aida oh you're cute but now
may Ruby mee-mah mee-mah mee-mah buff
bless me ma o me ma so strong okay all
right we got me ma we got Rowan we got
stinky a whole generation I'd like to
think that this is one big family like
this is me mom to Grandma the really
buff bodybuilder there's stinky the Papa
he's stinky and then Rose a little kid
Rowan likes to dig I like this
panopticon space bad ironically ironic
darkest raucous dreamland I almost
choked that was such a brilliant idea
great let's get into this okay all right
Oh Oh Lord it's all bad here
everything's horrible all right let's
get a scope of the land here okay you
all remember how to play cuz I do so we
need to make them not poop in the water
that's rule number one number two let's
we got a bill we got to get to
researching pretty soon because I got to
figure out what else they got going on
because they've done a lot of new stuff
in this oh god I gotta go all the way up
there for the metal
I need that [ __ ] okay so we're
starting over all the way at the
beginning again because as with most of
these updates the save system doesn't
work as well so we have to do what we
got to do so we're starting over the
beginning which means that I'm gonna be
accelerating a lot and I'm gonna be
flying by the seat of my pants on how
good I am at building [ __ ] ain't that
right everybody oh yeah right oh that is
so right but I gotta get metal before
I'm able to build anything else how
about you stop sitting around with your
hands up your ass and you go get the
metal go get the metal come on oh [ __ ]
the bathroom I almost forgot about the
bathroom daddy's unbelievably important
okay need the sink there go put those
things because I'm very particular about
cleanliness we need to get a plump
picture got after plump picture go get
that there dark it go go go go go I
forgot you got to make this priority
because otherwise people are gonna [ __ ]
themselves and that ain't good for
nobody
all right come on go go go go go go
I almost always forget about the pooping
station cuz if you forget about the
pooping station then you're gonna find
me you gotta have a lot of poop it's
pretty much the long in the short of it
you're gonna have a lot of poop where
you don't want poop and where you don't
want poop is in your water you know what
poop in water that's like that's
markiplier life lesson number one you
don't want poop in your water so keep
your poop out of your water you're gonna
have a great time and then you're gonna
of life they probably gonna die anyway
cuz something else Bad's gonna happen
but don't poop in your water that's
first and foremost about everything that
we got over here so I don't know what
the automation upgrade but we got to get
power going real soon let me get the
beds for them actually I'm not gonna I'm
gonna make it like a policy not to pause
because I have a habit of doing that but
I'm gonna I'm gonna really try not to
pause because there's uh there's so much
to be done here but I know that I can do
it good and I can do it justice if I
just who if I just very strategically
plan everything that I got going on
because if I don't Nanna bones but I'm
not boned because I'm smart like you
dare finally we're getting mad dull oh
wow we got the metal oh who the [ __ ] oh
just in time for sleep yeah that's good
alright but why what did I mention I'm
on one of the betas so prepare for some
strange functionality because I don't
know what's on there Jen maybe that's
just the familial chin the stinky me
Monroe and family chin redness that they
have going on there they got that we got
a little bit of oxygen flowing over
there so the next thing we got to do is
we got to get power going then we got to
get the research going so I'm gonna
build a ladder up here because this is
gonna be the research area ooh there's a
lot of goodies in there but I don't want
to dig too deep cuz it's about to get
germy
that's actually not dig deep that's
actually not that's not a priority at
all that is the opposite of a priority
right now okay okay so then we're gonna
build or manual Wow that wires so nice
the wire is like red now that's real I
don't like that actually something feels
wrong about that hmm alright whatever
it's fine at least I got a medal for
that alright get that done get that done
get the done kill that mark kill that
hatch kill that
come on now kill that hatch oh you sack
of [ __ ]
rod rummy ma you don't have to do
everything me MA you're such a hero oh
good okay kill that hatch cook cool
chill kill the hatch all right pause
again I'm sorry try not to do that
memo's me boss just like I've been
through this before it's not the worst
thing in the world
no no I'm emos from whatever country
that accent I did was from nowhere oh
yeah that place yeah but now that we got
this we can actually see the research
tree which means that we're gonna okay
whoa transit tube what transit tube so
they get sucked in like Futurama and
they could show all the tubular update
oh that makes sense
Oh comfy bed the plastic tile
ah there's so much [ __ ]
well gotta start somewhere let's get
farming up and ready to go but bang even
from the last time I played that's the
thing I love about this is that they
update the game so much like so
ridiculous what are you doing Rowan
stopping oh I can't do that Rowan stop
being idle go get some damn whatever
that is and get it ready I guess damn it
okay all right so we got to dig this
down we're gonna dig this that water
supplies need to connect to that water
supply but we got to mmm we got to like
robust that out but let's put some
storage containers like right ooh let's
also get a door
oh let's also get these wash basins only
to the right now if people don't use
them on the way in even though I do I'm
kind of one of them to be on the way in
just in case you never know you never
know
you never know Rowen please stop being
an idiot please that's all I ask
so once we get that oh we got that all
right let me see what the next one is
power regulation shirt all right so now
that we got that we can start our food
growing operation because we're gonna
need food right away baby I don't have
time to be very bad I think this room
needs to be that definitely doesn't need
to be there okay cuz this is gonna be a
door and a door cuz we are civilized
that's what we is definitely you're
gonna be there you're gonna be a door
and you're gonna be there and you're
gonna be there and then we're gonna
build more food because we don't have
enough people to survive okay what do we
have do we have seeds oh you know we got
seeds baby you know we got seeds oh you
know we got seeds let's put these bad
boys right there chair it's kind of an
open-air design around that big ol
portal thingy because we want to make
sure that we got the decorum all nice
and pretty like refinement compost you
know it baby
let's put that compost well we don't
exactly have a locked door also who's
best at researching uh not me ma they're
pretty good I guess
okay we're doing good we're doing good
we're doing good okay all right cool
cool cool we got two bits of research
done what do we need advanced research
oh you got to do that before you get
anything else to do you know okay all
right well let's go ahead and do that
automatic control enables access to the
automation overlay power shut off
automatically turns power on and off
using automation technology does not
affect your circuitry preceding the
switch signal switch automation wire
bridge automation wire generic sensors
wait plate what oh that's so cool
clock sensor oh oh I don't know I'm
never gonna fireball fireball I love
that brute force refinement produces
sand from raw minerals inefficiently
produces refined metals from raw
or oh well then that answers the
question of filtration there's finally a
way to make sand oh smelting produces
refined metals from raw metal or outputs
he significantly heated liquid he did
liquid what kind of heated liquid we
talking about we're talking about lava
sounds like we're talking about lava why
are we talking about lava I'm not
talking about lava you're talking about
lava all right whatever
we're gonna need more plants than that
after a while but for now that is is
what it is so that's good can you dig
that out please
please please can you dig that out okay
so far so good okay our next patient is
Artie mmm divers lungs I always like a
diver and learning which means that you
can be better at everything once you get
your head out of your ass
they're good cultured no you know what I
like you Artie I like you re re Oh
everybody got a new friend okay that's
the only one that we're gonna get for a
while because I don't want to be I don't
to be in the precarious situation of not
having enough room for anybody so Ari's
gonna be up there by herself so have fun
with that ari we also need to get
oxygenation going because the oxygen
can't stop okay the oxygen is not doing
bad because we got the socks light
that's flowing upwards but we're gonna
need the airflow tiles eventually before
we're able to get anywhere else so we
got to make sure we have that because if
we don't have that
well then weld bond hate to say it but
we're just gonna be straight-up banda
well there's so many goodies up in there
and let me make sure just to give my
people something to chew on
let's get these goodies let's get those
goodies this is a co terrorism our way
through this [ __ ] Jesus those guys are
gonna get a mouthful okay but so far so
oh really
Oh re as I sleep on the ladder ari come
on just move the sand just a little bit
come on now come on move the sand a
little bit oh come on ah [ __ ] there
ain't no the razors is damn it I like
the resources that we have I'm not gonna
kill too many of them because eventually
I want to hurt them all her not hurt
heard them all into cages so that I can
create a coal production facility
because these things eat the things that
I need but also they [ __ ] out coal so
it's like a 50-50 I mean if I had a but
if she could just start [ __ ] out
coal like one I'd be worried about what
I was feeding her but number two that
might be a profitable business so I
gotta be very savvy about it let's just
get all the basic [ __ ] out of the way
well I'm gonna build a supercomputer
here and we're eventually gonna get that
up and running but for now we got to get
this right stop being a stupid [ __ ] your
bit right now you've made a bit of a
stupid [ __ ] I like it I don't like it
not at all Rowan we stop being so stupid
okay we need to get oxygen so we need
algae terrariums but if we do have the
situation where we're gonna have a lot
more water because of the filtration
that we're gonna be having then this
offers an interesting solution that
we're gonna be able to have I think I
think I think along so you need a carbon
dioxide environment I'm thinking that
I'm gonna put you right right by the
water is gonna be a good spot for a year
you're gonna need I I guess you gotta
need a floor of some kind if I have to I
guess yeah all right sure whatever let
me see if I can extend this ladder down
I know they're gonna get hypothermia but
whatever do I actually care no you you
you you all right why is that considered
grisly this is stupid
whatever they order of the owner of the
mmm I wonder if they did anything
different about the microbe crusher
because if they actually made the the
cooking a little bit better than maybe
maybe it might be good to go for that
but for right now I know you know I'm
gonna go for the meal prep and hopefully
if it's gonna be something there why do
you have Harry ollie
Holly Holly Holly Holly
howdy howdy howdy howdy howdy okay all
right well then I don't know why she had
the red dot on her chin but okay all
right who's gonna be stinking up a star
berry you guys got your jobs all in
order yeah it's good
all right we got we got a world-class
diggin guy I know we should use that but
for right now I just hate to assign
people to individual jobs just early on
don't want to ruin them because if we
got those going that's a little bit of
something and these light bugs are gonna
give it some light that's so nice and at
least they got a lot of carbon dioxide
down there so that seems to be a pretty
effective trap for them I'm gonna put
another one down here but that's later
so far so good no stopping on this train
honk honk we're going forward so that's
some good to look forward to we need to
get more we're gonna need to get more
meal would definitely sooner rather than
later I'm just gonna need to go for the
air flow stuff like the the pneumatic
doors after they move ah no yes no yes
yes mechanical oh no yeah
pressure management okay we need to get
ventilation after we have the next one
and then we need to go for pressure
management there are a lot of you you
better not eat my metal you know what
just as a safety precaution number sweep
up that metal I don't know where we're
gonna sweep it to we don't have any well
I guess we should make some storage
containers shouldn't we hunk
well that sorry I got drunk for those
two seconds I was holding down the
button I paused it again - which is a
big no-no on the marquee Momo so we got
this super computer
oh is that new music I hear I would
recognize the new music because I know
all the songs in this I played it so
much I've got 84 hours logged in this
game by the way I am pathetic all right
well that hat seems to be stuck hey
buddy
mee-mah did you see that [ __ ] Mima did
you see this hatchets spook no no weird
but ok alright so that research is done
so the next we're gonna go for his
pressure management I'm just gonna set
that to task we're gonna get those
underway doodly-doo doodly-doo you know
it gets a lot easier when you don't have
too many duplicates and then you don't
have to feed them and worry about them
sucking up so much oxygen things
actually go a lot smoother when you just
do that oddly enough weird oh that is
new music oh that's delightful oh that's
a bounty to my ears oh that's beautiful
oh I love it okay who's stressed arey
probably cuz that spot on her chin but
she's gonna be okay just a little strip
mining that's it not too much I don't
want to give him impossible to complete
tasks from Iran we need to make sure the
auction is good we need to make sure the
food flow is good we need to make sure
that everything is good and then we can
start hammering away on the big bonk and
bumper stuff as I like to call the big
bump and bumper stuff ooh a natural gas
geyser well that's awfully handy we have
any other good geysers and [ __ ] around
some water leaking through there which
might mean that there's something up
there but I don't think so
there might just be a little bit of
water that is in those pockets they're
blue and remember the oil the oil
upgrade I forgot about that one the oil
upgrade is in the hot area as I should
have suspected but I'm now I'm not gonna
worry about that for a long time I've
got a long way to go before I get there
but I'm not gonna now I'm gonna take
that long to do it because I'm gonna
make sure that I survive right here and
right now all right I'm gonna get more
planter box up on this thing right here
seems like a good place as any I've got
that all right cool cool cool cool cool
cool cool
all right go to sleep little baby booze
we got ventilation which means that we
got the things that we need to be able
to make battle I wish you could just
like I wish you could just so as you
could just place that over and it would
do that because that'd be a smart thing
to do this is like blam and then it's on
there but no that
alas that is not what we're doing
wakey wakey eggs and Bakey come on we
gotta go we got a lot of stuff to do all
right we'll put that there
I know it's gotta get real real
oxygen-deprived in there but at least
it's gonna be okay wait is there any
polluted dirt happening over there wait
no that's no no wait hang on cancel that
cancel wait no that's right I wanted to
do that and then put the mechanized
airlock here so I could get the
refinement so I could turn our poop into
fertilizer that was what I was doing and
then I need oh that's right I needed to
create a dump for all the polluted water
that's what I needed to do that's what I
needed to do that's what I needed to do
okay I got it I got it so they're gonna
get that eventually Oh our first harvest
hell yeah oh hell yeah we got more meal
with seeds
hey you [ __ ] need to dig out this
stuff did you know that did you not know
that I bet you didn't know that all
right they're getting to work whoa what
oh okay all right well meemaw just took
a beatin holy [ __ ]
mee myuu okay Oh Mimas not doing so good
oh no moderate wounds oh that's so sad
me Mom sorry I mean you're really strong
so that kind of helps out your situation
but god damn you you deserve better than
that meemaw I don't care if you have to
eat worms
it doesn't mean a difference to me I
don't give a [ __ ]
you're gonna eat worms and it's gonna be
good so shut your [ __ ] mouth
fifth burthen only if they're really
convincing max look at your twinkle toes
I'm jarem resistant that's good we got
MEAP oh look at that unibrow but a mouth
breather never gonna happen
ooh Frankie noodle arms very immune
lotsa uh Frankie I like ya
I like you and I like your noodle arms I
do I really do
there's nothing Frankie's are more proud
of them they're thick dignified eyebrows
oh you know what Frankie I like you
Frankie I like you Frankie I don't want
to go but five all right no more than
five no more than five none no more than
five
I like Frankie the only reason is
because I'm totally biased and I'm I'll
change my mind of what I want at the
drop of a hat it's just how I am it's
how I am it's just how I am everybody
lamb we're gonna close this up and then
that's gonna be a room because once that
turns into a room there's a little bit
of whoo there's a little bit of a bonus
to it if it's a barracks room it's gonna
have a stamina recovery bonus stress
relief bonus bonus bonus mess all bonus
stress relief for the mess hall bonus
we're gonna make that soon we're gonna
make a big-ass mess hall that's gonna be
nice I make it up here since there's
space and then we're gonna make a med
bed bonus we're gonna have a bonus Bay
and a bonus bonus baby bonus baby and
that's gonna be it okay but that's all
the time that I got for this episode
this is a good start we're making
progress here and it's good to be back
in this game I do love this game a lot I
really do there's nothing like about it
that I don't like about it the challenge
of it the the intricacy of it that they
like struggle to survive of it and the
constant progress and updates just make
it super fun across the board so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know how you think down the comments
below there's gonna be more coming at
you real soon so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]